good morning Hank it's Tuesday today I
want to talk about death and how to
avoid it also there will be a signing
update at the end of this video but
first death so the other day I dropped
my kids off at camp and as I was helping
them out of the car one of them sneezed
directly on to my hands and then as I
was driving home I could literally feel
like the gross aerosolized cold virus
spit drying on my hands so I opened up
the center console and started looking
around for some Purell in there and that
was a tremendous and potentially fatal
miscalculation so I talked a lot about
how human life is getting better and in
almost every way it really is we are
healthier more prosperous and less
likely to die from violence than at any
point in human history but there are a
few ways that human life is actually
getting worse like wealth inequality for
instance has been growing although it's
still low by historical standards and
that's bad especially for the poor but
also for the whole social order because
it inhibits overall economic growth and
socio-economic mobility and then we have
the so called preventable death rate
here in the United States these are
deaths that could be prevented with
existing technology by reducing medical
errors or getting people to quit smoking
etc between 2010 and 2014
overall preventable deaths in the u.s.
decreased but preventable deaths by
so-called unintentional injury increased
by 23 percent which is a lot so what's
going on well as you can see here there
are three big reasons first Falls which
is going up mostly because the
population of the United States is
getting older and older people are far
more likely to die from falling and then
there is poisoning which is almost
entirely drug overdoses
so back in 1992 Americans were more than
three times as likely to be murdered
than they were to die of drug overdoses
but today Americans are more than three
times as likely to die of drug overdoses
than they are to be murdered that's
partly because homicide rates have
fallen by almost 40% but mostly because
drug overdoses are skyrocketing
drug overdoses are now the leading cause
of death for Americans under the age of
50 now the drug abuse crisis in the
United States is very complex there's a
great health care tree our series about
it that I will link to in the doobly-doo
below but what's clear is that what we
are doing about the substance abuse
crisis is woefully inadequate and I just
want to take a quick moment here to say
to anyone out there living with
substance abuse you are valuable and
deserve to be loved and supported and to
be well and there are lots of people
live wonderful lives in recovery I know
there are not enough options for
treatment but I hope you will seek help
today I've put some resources in the
doobly-doo below okay so lastly we have
motor vehicle accidents which brings me
back to my Purell miscalculation the
overall death rate from car accidents
has fallen a lot since 1975 with
improvements to car safety but in 2015
it actually rose by 7% some of that is
probably attributable to more miles
being driven as the economy continued to
improve but most of it is because of
distracted driving too many of us are
using our phones while we drive or
playing pokemon go or reaching for
Purell I didn't get in a car accident
while trying to find that Purell just as
most of the time people don't get in car
accidents when they text while driving
but I nonetheless dramatically increased
my risk of dying and also my risk of
killing someone else far more than
whatever infinitesimally I have as a
result of the cold virus on my hands so
I'm making this video mostly as a
reminder to myself when I am driving the
greatest threat to my health and
well-being by far is not whatever text I
just received or whatever spit is drying
on my hands its inattentive driving all
right it's all right that sounded like a
long PSA it's just there's so few things
in life that we can actually fix and
this is one of them signing update I
have about 34,000 copies to go that's
about 68 hours of signing which I think
is doable also I am told that Amazon
will soon run out of their allotment of
signed copies of turtles all the way
down don't worry there will still be
tons of signed copies at bookstores all
over the US and Canada and you can
always stay up to date on how to get a
probably signed copy and probably signed
turtles calm but if you want to get one
from Amazon now is probably the time
links in the doobly-doo below hank you
will see me actually on Thursday because
Esther day